hey guys  don't read your life has value you are  worthy of love go outside there's  literally no excuse netflix hulu hbo max  you think i got this way without going  through my own struggles i used to be  addicted i used to think there were no  other options for me i was trapped in an  endless cycle and oh it's ready  i forgot to put anything in there  reading will make you do stupid [ __ ]  this is my roku remote what does it say  disney plus netflix hulu sling where's  books who put this here what kind of  sick joke this isn't mine  it's not what it looks like i'm holding  these for a friend  i'm sorry i try man i can't give them  all up they do as i say not as i do  100 of people who read books will be  dead by the end of their lifetime